whenever we query the database we get a
cursor back that contains columns each
column has an integer index assigned to
it up until now we've had to call get
column index for each column in order to
get this index but there's a way to
avoid doing that we can create a
projection which is just an array of the
columns we want to return in our cursor
this is more efficient because we are
only fetching the data from the database
that we need to use and since the
database always returns the columns in
the order we specify we can rely on the
indices matching the order from our
projection so we can then just use these
indices to get information from our
cursor one minor note since we are doing
a joint on our weather with location
queries we have to specify which ID we
want explicitly in our projection by
adding the table name followed by a dot
before the column name as in this
example